so hi folks I'm pleased how's everyone
doing right now how how am i doing I'm
doing okay thanks for asking oh no I'm
actually really really stoked to be here
because I love Hawaii I love going to
the beach and surfing and doing things
in the ocean this is me on a recent
scuba trip here but a recreational
diving doesn't really pay the bills so I
do a little bit of software engineering
on the side and my first engineering job
was in 2015 where I worked at an unnamed
company I'd been coding small things on
my own like Neopets
storefronts and myspace fiends since I
was a teenager but this was my yeah who
knew pets or once I moved from MySpace
either way this is my first time working
on a team and building a capital P
product and this was also my first
introduction to graph QL so show of
hands how many people here have worked
with graph QL before cool cool cool so
yeah graph QL is a query language in an
application it fits in the API layer
much like rest does how many people here
have worked with REST API s how many
people here worked with graph QL before
they ever worked with a REST API handle
nice but yeah I still think it's unusual
to have this experience of learning and
working with graph QL first and I think
that that early exposure set the
foundation for how I view product
development overall and this is a
picture of me realizing that
imagine if your first introduction to
web development was through something
like react and I'm sure that for many of
you you don't even have to imagine that
but you'd probably understand that that
kind of introduction left a unique
impression on you and it molded your way
of thinking about web app development
right and I think that that's the case
with me and Graziella and product
development as well so in the first
engineering job I worked on recruiting
products we built a suite of products
and tools that our recruiters used to do
their jobs in my sound kind of
surprising but for a company of that
size that recruits on that scale
greenhouse just doesn't cut it so it's
actually a cost saver to have an
internal team building those tools for
you and for recruiting that statement is
true partly because of the scale that we
were dealing with like more than a
million candidates in our pool thousands
of interviews every day hundreds of
thousands of recruiting decisions that
have to be made every day from resume
reviews to final offers but that's also
true because recruiting is an incredibly
complex problem domain and what do I
mean by complex problem domain let's
define domain when I talk about domain
I'm talking about the subject area for
which you are building software so on my
old team our domain was the tech
recruiting space I had to understand how
the industry sources candidates how
often recruiters engage candidates and
in what ways and how people prepare for
interviews and a lot more and then what
do I mean by complex it's important to
differentiate complicated from complex
complicated is about many rules and
steps but predictable ones and getting
predictable results from the same sets
of inputs think like taxes software
American taxes are super complicated but
it can be simplified by pruning or
consolidating steps and that's what the
taxes software does but complex is
different we can't easily turn a complex
problem into a set of predictable rules
to follow
because complex problems are fuzzy
relationship-driven and constantly
evolving so by definition there's no
solution to a complex problem like
recruiting and trying to solve it once
and for all is kind of misguided the
best we can do is continuously manage it
how do we manage a complex problem
domain let's find out I worked on that
team for a while and I learned a ton
about the recruiting space a lot about
graffiti whoa and a lot about product
development and then I went to work at a
small start-up whose tech stack was
really similar to my old team except no
graph QL and I sat in meetings and I
read over a technical specs and things
just felt different not worse because
God forbid I say anyone technology is
worse than another just different and
the things we focused on were different
the way we discuss problems was
different and I think that that contrast
shed a light on my past experience and
helped me develop opinions on a product
development within a complex product
domain should look like I had an aha
moment or more like a series of aha
moments when I started to think about
where this difference came from so I
wanted to share some of those opinions
with y'all in this talk called graph QL
the domain way by the end of this talk I
hope to convince you of this that graph
2l gives product teams superpowers by
letting them focus on their domain
rather than their data and I also hope
that you can learn something that will
be helpful to you as a product developer
even if you don't use graph QL yet
let's do a high-level overview really
grateful that Shawn showed you all some
cool graphic UL stuff yesterday because
it takes the pressure off of this part a
little bit if I said us before graph 2 I
was a query language it's also a runtime
for fulfilling those queries so to be
clear it's not a programming language
and it's not a graph database in fact
graph GL was pretty agnostic about both
of these things there are graph QL
implementations out there in JavaScript
obviously but also ruby scala closure
doesn't care what programming language
you implement it in and you can use
whichever and however many different
data sources you want with it
this graphic shows where graph QL sits
as the API layer between all of your
possible clients and all of your data
sources it can talk to any kind of
database micro-service a third party API
it can act as a layer to a legacy system
it can talk to another graph QL server
or to an existing REST API the rest it's
important to understand that graph QL
doesn't replace your data layer concerns
but it does let you decouple those
concerns from your product domain
concerns I'm gonna keep showing you some
snippets of graph QL alongside the rest
of this talks content but this is all we
need to know to get started so changing
teams got me curious about different
product development philosophies out
there and eventually I came across one
called
domain driven development I think that
graph QL and domain driven development
go really well with each other and
hopefully you think so too by the end of
this talk but even if you don't use
graph QL if you're building software
within a complex domain the principles
of DDD can really help you collaborate
better and build a better product for
your user I want to talk about five
strategies within domain driven
development that I feel are most
relevant to my own product development
experience and to graph QL we'll go
through each strategy one by one so
don't worry if these go fast I just want
to let you know what's coming the first
strategy is finding the important parts
of the problem second strategy
oops second one is creating a model that
solves that problem then we collaborate
to using a shared language to build a
better model we make sure to separate
our domain logic from our infrastructure
logic and we also make sure to clearly
document all of our changes so let's go
to the first strategy breaking down the
problem that you're trying to solve and
highlighting what the most important
parts are even outside of DDD or using
graph QL this is a pretty important part
of software development right when you
work within a complex domain there's a
wealth of information but not all of it
is rel
to the problem at hand you can find
where to put your focus by breaking down
your problem and asking which parts
deliver the most value building software
is really expensive way to solve a
problem and I think not everything
merits a problem solution so a product
solution I mean so it's important to be
thoughtful about these things let's
practice finding the important parts of
a problem with a sample problem and by
the way this is the problem that I made
up I never worked on anything like this
so don't come after me for exposing
trade secrets or whatever on average 20%
of our interviewers cancel their
interview slot less than 24 hours before
their scheduled interview
this means that coordinators are rushing
to fill slots and when they can't it's a
really bad candidate experience I see
two sub problems here problem a is that
20% of interviewers cancel and problem B
is coordinators have to drop everything
and rush to find a fill-in which problem
do you think we should solve with a
product solution vote now on your phones
okay now there's no voting but to know
which is the right problem to solve
you need to have domain knowledge which
you can get by talking to domain experts
so let's think about problem a for a
little bit why do people cancel maybe
they had a scheduling conflict
maybe they got sick how much lower could
we change this number realistically like
maybe we can make it go from 20 percent
to 10 percent so 10 percent of
candidates would still have a really bad
experience but what about so problem B
coordinators have to rush to fill in
interview slots at the last minute if we
can make that process really easy or
non-existent then it's okay for some
interviewers to cancel so we can go and
talk to an expert in our domain like an
interview coordinator and ask what they
think and they might say something like
you know a lot of times people cancel
because they're sick and we can't really
do anything to change that I would
rather just have a backup interviewer or
a tool that makes it super easy to find
one and now we know where to focus our
product building acts efforts then the
next step
getting to work and designing a model
that solves the problem it's easy for me
as an engineer to start chasing a
perfect abstraction so I have to try
really hard to keep in mind the actual
business need that this project
addresses remember that we're building a
product within a complex domain it's
kind of a waste of time to try to build
a perfect mapping between the real world
and your API layer because by definition
the complex domain we're working in is
fuzzy and ever-changing so I think we
just have to accept that we're not gonna
reach domain model harmony and our best
approach is to build an evolvable model
that brings us that business value now
and a good question to ask yourself here
is what's the smallest possible change I
can make to deliver this value to answer
that question we need to know the
current state of the world and this is
where I want to introduce you all to a
core concept in graph two I'll call the
schema the schema is where you define
all the data that is available to the
client the basic building block is the
type and a type can have fields and also
relationships to other types the
graphical schema is where you model your
business domain so any important entity
in your domain could be defined as a
type on the schema here's an example of
a type of the interview type written in
schema definition language what's the
shape of an interview type well it has
an ID a start in an endtime a room that
it's held in a status which could be
like scheduled or completed it has an
interview type which could be like a
systems interview or front-end coding it
also has relationships to other types
that are defined elsewhere on the schema
Canada interviewer interview and vie and
the interview loop but it's a part of
remember we were talking about how graph
QL is like an abstraction layer over all
of the places you want to get your data
from I see the schema also as an
abstraction but over your business
domain and I found a really natural to
use schema definition language in
product development because the graph
based system resembles my natural mental
model for relationships between real
world things and maybe someone who are
looking at this and thinking how is this
different from a database model the
sir has to do with what we're focusing
on when we're designing each when
designing a database structure we care
about things like consistency redundancy
and efficiency on the back end when
designing a graphic UL schema we care
about the needs of our front-end client
specifically when writing the schema
it's definitely tempting to just
recreate a 101 in mapping to your
underlying database setup or to your
existing REST API but by doing so you're
introducing unnecessary complexity on
the client side let's look at an example
let's say this is the UI we're building
floor please don't judge my design
skills too harshly I get mistaken for a
designer all the time but I definitely
don't have those skills we want to
display information about an interview
loop namely we want to display the
candidate name the job that they applied
for and then a list of their interviews
including their interviewers name and
their feedback what would that look like
if our graph UL types were just mappings
to our database we'll start from the
interview loop on the left is our domain
style schema definition and on the right
is our database style schema definition
you'll see that the difference is that
the relationships to other types are
represented by string IDs instead of by
the actual type so assuming we're gonna
use our database style schema how does
this affect the way that we write our
client code buckle in this is what a
query in graph QL looks like in this one
we're giving some interview loop ID and
asking for the IDS of the candidate the
job requisition and all the interviews
on the loop we stored those IDs and then
we kick off some other queries we do
three more queries to get the candidate
name the job requisition title and then
all the data that we need for each of
the interviews and we're still not done
because for each of those interviews we
also need to get the interviewers name
and then there's a bunch of code that we
still have to write to parse this data
and map it into the right format
remember this is more complex than it
needs to be because of our decision to
make our graph QL schema map to our
databases what would this look like if
we design our schema to match our mental
model instead if we wrote our schema
tonight
our mental model we can get exactly the
data that we want in the shape that we
want with just one request being able to
write queries like this simplifies our
work on the client by a lot and if we
ran this query this would be the data
that we get back we have our candidate
Barack Obama who applied for a product
engineer role and was interviewed by
Michelle Obama which is not a conflict
of interest at all don't worry after you
get some initial ideas down it's time to
work together with your team to make it
good and for this part to go well
everyone has to have a shared
understanding of your domain and even
more importantly an established shared
language to talk about it with why is
this part so important without a shared
language collaboration between teams
within a company is really inefficient
you're gonna mix business jargon with
technical jargon and everyone is just
going to be constantly talking past each
other without even realizing it having a
shared language removes a large chunk of
ambiguity and misinterpretation and it
ultimately saves you time and especially
when we're building for complex domains
we need to iterate quickly to keep up
with the ever-changing nature of our
domain so we need those tight feedback
loops so I take my text back and I set
up a meeting actually I'm gonna call it
a working session after Anna's talk
yesterday I really like that I set up a
working session with maybe one other
engineer a p.m. a designer and a domain
expert so my last job our domain experts
were longtime recruiters and recruiting
managers these are the people who have
the most on-the-ground realistic
knowledge of your domain so you're
really doing yourself a disservice if
you don't include them early in your
development process I'm gonna say it
again because I think it's really
important talk to your domain experts
like think right now who are your domain
experts for the area that you work in
and how can you include them in your
development process more where were we
okay we're in the working session we're
collaborating on our proposed changes
and in the session we talked about a lot
of things but I wanted to share some
concrete tips for building and
maintaining a shared vocabulary or as
it's called in domain driven development
you
kotas language first ensure that you
only use one word for specific concept
don't let domain experts and developers
have two words that address the same
thing second try to stay away from
overloaded technical terms like service
policy manager etc in your API layer
words in your API layer should
correspond to concepts in your domain
third create and maintain a glossary of
terms with explicit definitions this is
something that you get basically for
free with graph key well it's really
cool and I'll show you how in a bit use
terms from your shared language
everywhere namespaces classes filenames
properties method names you should also
be able to find the same language that
you use in your code in your support
articles in your internal update emails
in your product specs this is how you
keep a shared language alive and useful
by using it and then as you gain a
deeper understanding of your business
domain your shared language will evolve
as well periodically refactor your code
base to reflect this this is also
something that's much easier to do in a
typed and well-documented code base like
one that uses graph QL and I know that
this sounds like a lot of work but it's
necessary work because there is always
going to be some underlying model and if
you're not putting conscious effort into
building a useful and evolvable model
then you're probably modeling garbage by
accident this is the kind of upfront
work that makes sure that you're solving
the right problem that you have the
correct assumptions about your domain
and that you're not making some
incorrect assumption into your model
that's going to give you headaches for
years to come another strategy in DDD is
separating your business logic from your
infrastructure logic and if you get
nothing else from this talk here's a
life hack for separating egg yolks
and why is it important to keep these
things separate not the egg yolks I mean
the different logic types over time your
product priorities change or your
understanding of your product domain
changes and so your product itself
changes there's a regular cadence within
which you add new features and whatnot
at the same time as your company grows
and it grows its user base you probably
also will need to make some
infrastructure changes to accommodate
that but those are two separate things
right you're changing product needs and
then you're changing scale needs a lot
of complexity in applications comes from
these two things being entangled when we
want them to be isolated so that they
can grow and change at their own pace
remember our good old schema graph QL
has a special type called query this is
a special type because it defines the
entry point for all of your data for
every type in our schema and for every
field on every type we have to teach
graph QL where that data actually lives
and how to get it we do this in the
resolvers and the resolvers are
functions that tell graph QL where and
how to resolve the types you've defined
this is where you'd write the code that
accesses your data source whatever it
may be let's look at this example
I wrote a MongoDB example but remember
you can put logic to ask us anything in
the resolvers in this example we have a
query called all interviews that returns
you guessed it all the interviews from a
MongoDB document we also have a query
called interviews by candidate that lets
you filter the interviews using a
candidate ID oh by the way if you like
this editor theme amy webelo made it
it's called fairy floss check it out as
I said before a few times in domain
driven development it's really important
for the whole team to have a shared
understanding of the business domain and
a shared language to use when talking
about it so you need to document
everything and I know that everyone says
this in like this really aspirational
way but graphic you graph to out really
does make this much easier because of
the type system your domain is
practically self documenting there's
this really cool tool
video playing yeah no is it yeah there's
this really cool tool called graphical
it's a sandbox for your graph QL schema
and here I have a video of graphical
over the github graph QL API if you want
to try out graph QL this is a really
good place to get started you can write
and run arbitrary queries and get real
data back and my favorite part is the
documentation Explorer on the right
where you can navigate and search
through every type that you've defined
in your schema including descriptions
for every type a protip is you can make
descriptions a required field for any
new type in your schema and you've got
built in documentation that way let's do
a recap at the beginning of the talk I
said that graph QL gives product team
superpowers by letting them focus on
their domain rather than their data and
we've learned that this domain focused
way of structuring your work is called
domain driven development how our graph
QL and domain driven development tied
together one it's impossible for a
schema designed to be an afterthought
because for anything to work in your API
you have to define it in your schema
first and this forces you to think
upfront about your schema and your
domain graph based modeling feels really
natural and speeds up development on the
client side the schema definition
reduces communication errors between
teams because everyone is on the same
page about what terms mean and what
relationships between types look like
you get built-in separation of concerns
between your domain and your infra logic
because of the resolvers and you get
really nice documentation with very
little extra effort because of the type
system and the awesome tooling that's
available in the graph QL ecosystem and
after all of this maybe some of y'all
are thinking it sounds like a lot of
work and a lot of meetings and first of
all yeah if you're not working in a
complex problem domain this is
definitely overkill but otherwise
personally getting to work more
collaboratively is one of the things
that I love about working with graphs
well and following DDD it's exposed me
to new domains and new opportunities too
about those domains so I got to
understand the entire recruiting
pipeline very in-depth and on my current
job I've gotten to learn a bunch about
political organizing how nonprofits run
and a ton about text messages as a
platform I also strongly believe that
the best product engineering teams don't
just use the most cutting-edge tech or
focus on building pristine code bases
they also think and care deeply about
their products their users and their
domain if you want to learn more about
DDD Eric Evans's domain driven design is
the canonical text and I also use
patterns principles and practices of
domain driven design aka the PPP of DDD
and if you'd like to hear more about
graph QL and domain driven design
specifically this talk by mark Andre
zero from graph QL Summit last year is
really good and also talks about it and
finally Emily Griffin made those
adorable illustrations you can find her
on Twitter at Emily with curls
you should totally Commission her to do
art for your next talk so that's it
thanks everyone
[Applause]
you